[Applauso]
buon pomeriggio
sliding doors vi ricordate di questo
film sliding doors con gwyneth paltrow
lei era ed è una ragazza che è una
mattina va al lavoro scopre di essere
stata licenziata torna a casa va verso
la metropolitana e si avvicina al treno
per per prenderlo provviso mente il
treno arriva e il film prende due
traiettorie due strade la prima in cui è
sempre del treno la seconda in cui non
lo prende due traiettorie molto diverse
l'una dall'altra
ecco noi siamo un'associazione un po
simile con delle sliding doors davanti e
con una differenza però è essenziale
mentre helen di forca va la sua vita in
modo del tutto casuale
nel nostro caso invece una nostra scelta
abbiamo noi scegliere quale strada
prendere siamo ad un bivio dobbiamo
scegliere quale strada
quale strada affrontare perché e perché
soprattutto dobbiamo farlo in grande
fretta
lo abbiamo sentito un po stamattina il
cambiamento climatico sta arrivando e
sta arrivando più rapidamente di quanto
ci si aspettava tutte le previsioni che
noi come abbiamo fatto negli ultimi
trent'anni si sono rivelate sbagliate
per difetto
abbiamo previsto poco cambiamento
rispetto a quello che se effettivamente
avverata
un esempio lo scioglimento di ghiaccio
quest'anno il l'artico il polo nord
aveva un volume che era un quarto è una
superficie di gara la metà di quella che
era
venti anni fa e questo implica
innalzamento del livello del mare
implica inondazioni nelle zone costiere
e spostamenti di popolazione ricoltura
siccità incendi produzione agricola in
declino e popolazioni che non riescono
più a vivere là dove erano prima
collocate il caso del lago turkana della
goccia da sono casi eclatanti milioni di
persone che si stanno spostando si
stanno su stan non si sposteranno si
stanno spostando perché le condizioni di
vita non sono più adatte alla loro
permanenza in quelle in quelle aree la
banca mondiale stima che per il 2050
saranno 143 milioni i migranti interni
dovuti ai cambiamenti climatici 143
milioni
una parte di questi diventerà anche
migranti internazionali e non basteranno
le chiusure dei porti per fermarli
sarebbe come un dito nel buco della diga
il problema quindi è sempre più
pressante e dobbiamo iniziare
affrontarlo e la causa inoppugnabile
la causa sono le nostre emissioni di gas
a effetto serra che hanno cambiato in
tempi molto rapidi rispetto alle
variazioni climatiche del passato il
clima in cui stiamo vivendo questo
grafico che vedete è già stato
menzionato da da dino zardi ma ve lo
faccio rivedere perché hanno ancora più
chiaro negli ultimi 800 mila anni quindi
ben prima che la specie umana apparisse
su questo pianeta
le concentrazioni gas serra non erano
mai state così elevate come oggi erano
state all'incirca 2 72 82 90 parti per
milione in volume oggi siamo arrivati a
non era mai successo che la specie umana
vivesse in queste condizioni
climatiche con un concentrato di gas
serra come quella che abbiamo oggi
quindi è una zona di altissimo rischio
di grande incertezza e di un potenziale
danno che dobbiamo affrontare è il
cambio climatico non è un problema di
domani è un problema già di oggi la
quantificazione economica che che vedete
qui ne è la tangibile verifica l'anno
scorso i danni da camerino climatico
sono stati 190 miliardi di dollari come
casi sono e come sono calcolati
calcolando quegli eventi quei quei gli
impatti che sono al di fuori della norma
al di fuori della della tendenza usuale
degli anni precedenti e che possiamo
quindi attribuire camino climatico e
questi danni risalgono sono saliti a 190
miliardi di dollari 0 25 del pil
mondiale per l'italia sono circa 4
miliardi ma in realtà essendo una zona
molto più vulnerabile il danno per
l'italia nel 2017 l'ultimo anno per cui
abbiamo dei dati affidabile di circa 66
miliardi perché anche i danni sono
distribuiti in modo molto eterogeneo ci
sono paesi che ci che guadagnano
altamento climatico e paesi ovviamente
che ci perdono e perdono molto e le zone
più vulnerabili sono anche le zone più
povere del pianeta
mi permetto anche un inciso oggi abbiamo
parlato molto di futuro abbiamo parlato
di futuro pensando molto a noia ma come
sta cambiando d'europa in realtà come
stanno cambiando i paesi ricchi ma oggi
un miliardo e 300 milioni di persone non
hanno nemmeno accesso all'indennità
immaginare che canta vent'anni
quei cambiamenti saranno arrivati anche
in quelle popolazioni del pianeta
li dobbiamo invece pensare a cose molto
mondo più basilari come dare elettricità
dall'istruzione dare cibo e facendo
tutto questo in modo coerente e
sostenibile con le risorse che abbiamo
senza aumentare gli impatti dei
cambiamenti climatici
chiudono inciso il problema è che finora
abbiamo fatto come gli struzzi abbiamo
ignorato semplicemente ignorato il
problema ma sapete che negli ultimi
quarant'anni da quando sappiamo che
nemmeno prima tv una minaccia da quando
abbiamo cominciato a negoziare accordi
internazionali per ridurre emissioni
abbiamo cominciato negli anni 80 il
primo importante firmato è stato a rio
de janeiro nel 92
da allora le emissioni non sono mai
cresciuto così tanto abbiamo emesso di
più da quando sappiamo negli ultimi 40
anni che non in tutta la storia
dell'umanità precedente paradossale
eppure così abbiamo fatto di struzzi
c'era un problema l'abbiamo ignorata
in realtà di struzzi non fanno così sono
più intelligenti l'homo sapiens che fa
così e questo cosa significa significa
che se prendessimo questa strada sliding
doors davanti se questa è forse la
strada beh l'incremento di temperatura
definito in modo tutto sommato molto
preciso al 2040 continuando su questa
traiettoria sarebbe già di un grado e
mezzo
tenete conto che un grado lo abbiamo già
acquisito quindi sarebbe un ulteriore a
mezzo grado e la crescita a fine secolo
sarebbe di 4 o 5 gradi condizioni
assolutamente incompatibili con la
presenza della specie umana sul nostro
pianeta
e questa una possibilità però ne abbiamo
un altro
l'altra possibilità è comportarsi in
modo intelligente e lavorare rapidamente
per una decarbonizzazione del nostri
sistemi socio economici i nostri sistemi
produttivi dei nostri e delle nostre
città e delle nostre abitazioni
la strategia del sommato a tre pilastri
facilmente facilmente definibili molto
chiari
il primo l'efficienza energetica
possiamo fare le stesse cose che oggi
facciamo consumando molta meno energia
abbiamo tutte le tecnologie per farlo e
sono questa di organizzazione e di
investimenti e di risorse
la seconda è elettrificare tutto ciò che
è possibile verificare i trasporti
abbiamo sentito ma anche di abitazioni i
processi produttivi
se riusciamo a criticare tutto quanto
possiamo elettrificare ovviamente
andiamo nella direzione di ridurre
fortemente le emissioni di gas serra
a patto che quell energia elettrica sia
prodotta poi con energie rinnovabili o
con un creare o con tecniche di cattura
della co2
queste sono sono i tre pilastri il
problema è che non ci siamo ancora e
nemmeno è sufficiente
perché non è sufficiente perché così
riusciremo ad azzerare il flusso di
emissioni ed emissioni che produciamo
ogni anno ma non basta perché ne abbiamo
gia emesse così tanti in atmosfera che
se non togliamo una parte di quelle che
abbiamo già emesso non riusciamo a
mantenere l'incremento di temperatura
non solo al di sotto di un altro mezzo
grado ma nemmeno di sotto di un altro un
grado e io sono convinto che
probabilmente arriveremo a due gradi di
incremento di temperatura e questo
potrebbe ancora essere accettabile il
problema è che alle condizioni attuali
siamo su una traiettoria di 3 gradi tra
galli e mezzo quattro gradi
assolutamente incompatibile con la
presenza della specie umana su questo
pianeta
qui dobbiamo lavorare per azzerare le
emissioni ma anche per togliere una
parte delle missioni janis e non abbiamo
le tecnologie per farlo non abbiamo
tecnologie per togliere co2 su larga
scala ovviamente su piccola scala
ci sono dei bei sicuramente nelle
soluzioni sull'arca sarà per togliere la
co2 emessa nel passato così come non
abbiamo altre tecnologie per esempio per
immagazzinare su larga scala energia
quella prodotta in con le rinnovabili
che è soggetta a fenomeni intermittenza
quando c'è il sole
possiamo produrla ma quando non c'è
dobbiamo immagazzinarla per poter
riutilizzare non abbiamo tecnologie per
difenderci dal cammello primario ad
esempio per da desalinizzare a basso
costo
altra cosa fondamentale per risolvere i
problemi di produzione agricola
soprattutto nei paesi in via di sviluppo
che dipendono in gran parte da quelle
produzione deriva non abbiamo tecnologie
fondamentali quindi abbiamo bisogno
quindi di investire
innanzitutto investire in ricerca
sviluppo e progresso tecnico
e qui abbiamo un'altra cattiva notizia
perché paradossalmente nonostante
sappiamo tutto questo nonostante il
nostro obiettivo sia riuscire a
sviluppare queste tecnologie ne va della
nostra sopravvivenza perché non farlo
guardate qui livelli di investimenti in
ricerca e sviluppo in campo energetico
sono più o meno quelli che avevano negli
anni 80 sono scesi negli anni 90 poi
sono risaliti ma tutto sommato non c'è
stato quell'incremento quello sforzo che
avremmo voluto vedere e che i leader dei
20 paesi fini stati usati in cui la
fotografia grazie alle mie spalle
avevano sottoscritto perché avevano
sottoscritto un patto si amava mission
innovation per fare questo grande sforzo
un investimento che realtà non è stato
non è stato fatto
siamo quindi in una situazione assai
paradossale
abbiamo bisogno di innovazione e ne
abbiamo bisogno rapidamente abbiamo
questi questi due treni in questi due
percorsi queste questa necessità di
sviluppare rapidamente soluzioni per
ridurre le emissioni di gas effetto
serra perché il cambiando climatico che
si muove si muove lentamente ma è già
partito e come ho detto prima i livelli
di emissione sono già al di là della
soglia di compatibilità
abbiamo quindi bisogno di accelerare la
transizione energetica e tutto ciò che
serve per ridurre le emissioni di gas
effetto serra una corsa contro il tempo
una corsa
una corsa che uno dei due potrà vincere
potrà vincere la specie umana la sua
sopravvivenza solo saremo capaci di
destinare abbastanza risorse con visione
con lungimiranza verso l'obiettivo di
ridurre ridurre le emissioni di gas a
effetto serra
il servono investimenti servono
investimenti e queste sono le stime che
abbiamo fatto recentemente sulle risorse
necessarie per ridurre le emissioni
come vedete nel corso degli anni dai pc
sia aumentato le proprie stime perché
siamo accorti che più settori erano
impattate più risorse servivano per
cambiare i modelli di produzione
piuttosto che le fonti energetiche
utilizzate nei vari comparti produttivi
provvedete che l'incremento ci porta una
cifra intorno ai 1.500 miliardi all'anno
di investimenti non sono costi sono
investimenti che è più o meno quello che
oggi si spende in termini di
investimenti in infrastrutture
energetiche non ha cifra fuori del
contesto è più o meno quello che oggi
spendiamo adesso però dobbiamo ri
direzionarlo spostarlo a spostare gli
investimenti impossibili fossi in
investimenti in rinnovabili
una parte di queste risorse ce l'abbiamo
l'anno scorso sono stati 500 miliardi di
investimenti nella giusta direzione
quasi tutti il 93 per cento in
mitigazione c'è una riduzione di
emissioni il 7 per cento in adattamento
quasi tutti i nuovi impianti per
produzione di energia con rinnovabili
perché non perché le imprese ci sono
investitori privati essenzialmente non
perché le imprese abbiano sensibilità
ambientale o grande lungimiranza ma per
più grande re senso di responsabilità ma
semplicemente perché con vieri
oggi produrre energia con le rinnovabili
costa meno che produrre con i
combustibili fossili
in particolare in paesi in via di
sviluppo ma anche da noi anche anche da
noi oggi un chilowattore prodotto con
fonti fossili costa meno che non
prodotto con usate con rinnovabili costa
meno che non prodotto confusi fossili
quindi questi 500 miliardi sono spostati
e vanno nella giusta direzione
però non basta perché abbiamo visto
prima servono circa 1.500 miliardi ne
mancano mille da dove possono venire
questi questi mille un parte accentuando
lo spostamento qui le politiche possono
fare molto
dare un prezzo alle emissioni di gas
serra far pagare chi produce emissioni
gas serra ovviamente una strada
essenziale difficile da percorrere
bisogna fare molto attenti agli effetti
distributivi ma sicuramente è essenziale
se ne sono delle altre qui viene
menziona alcun e l'efficienza energetica
ad esempio di cui abbiamo già parlato
può fare moltissimo la l'agenzia
internazionale dell'energia stima in 280
miliardi di dollari all'anno
il risparmio che potremo ottenere
applicando implementando soluzioni
tecnologiche già oggi esistono il
progresso tecnico da questo punto di
vista aiuta il prezzo di queste
soluzioni è sceso tantissimo parlavo
prima di fotovoltaico 20 volte in
vent'anni e la riduzione di prezzo per
produrre un chilowattora quel
fotovoltaico 20 volte in vent'anni ma
anche lampadina led piuttosto che
l'eolico e altre tecnologie sono
crollate i prezzi sono crollati negli
ultimi anni ovviamente questo aumenta
l'incentivo ad investire in quella
direzione
delibera risorse che possono essere
ulteriormente investito
ma ce ne sono altri 400 miliardi sono i
sussidi ai combustibili fossili nei
paesi del g20 non menzioni paesi in via
di sviluppo perché in questi paesi i
sussidi ai combustibili fossili sono
spesso una forma di sostegno al reddito
di aiuto alle popolazioni ma nei g 20
nei paesi più ricchi 20 paesi più ricchi
sono 400 miliardi all'anno i sussidi
combustibili fossili quattro volte i
sussidi alle rinnovabili
invertiamo il rapporto cominciamo così e
già questo liberebbe importanti risorse
per finanziare investimenti che riducano
le emissioni di gas serra
i permessi di emissione qui sarà una
cosa un po più tecnica però in europa ma
adesso anche in cina in molti stati
degli stati uniti e mettere mettere il
per produrre gas serra
bisogna pagare un permesso difetto di
molti paesi inclusa l'italia che i
permessi vengono regalati e quindi le
imprese devono pagare soltanto quella
componente quella parte che al di sopra
di quelli che vengono regalati ma se
fossero invece messi all'asta come fa la
germania ad esempio che ne mette una
gran parte all'asta e le imprese pagano
il prezzo migliore per avere questi
permessi
avremo una quantità enorme di risorse da
investire in ricerca innovazione da
investire in nuove soluzioni
tecnologiche per ridurre le emissioni
anche qui la stima che oggi abbiamo è
che senza mettere all'asta siamo già
arrivati al 15 miliardi in europa di
investimenti ogni anno utilizzando i
ricavi della vendita di permessi ma se
mettessimo all'asta anche una piccola
frazione meno della metà di questi
permessi
arriveremo a 150 200 miliardi all'anno
enormi risorse che potrebbero essere
investite guardate che sono tutte
soluzioni di fatto a saldi di bilancio
invariate a costo zero per i bilanci
pubblici e quindi non potrebbe dire no
ma siamo indebitati abbiamo altre
priorità
tutto questo si può fare senza andare a
toccare il resto e poi c'è un'altra
innovazione quelli che siamo il green
bonds sono titoli in cui chi emette il
titolo si impegna a utilizzare quelle
risorse per ridurre le emissioni stanno
crescendo tantissimo negli ultimi
quattro anni sono cresciuti da 20
miliardi dell'anno a 200 miliardi
all'anno in quattro anni è una scelta
che volete fare anche voi in generale a
livello internazionale c'è sempre più
attenzione per questo tipo di
investimenti e questa un'altra strada da
cui ottenere attraverso cui ottenere le
risorse che ci servono per ridurre le
emissioni passo cruciale come abbiamo
abbiamo visto prima perché tra 20 30
anni noi possiamo avere condizioni di
vita su questo pianeta compatibili con
la nostra sopravvivenza e non c'è
soltanto questo perché in realtà di
questo tipo di politiche non porta
benefici soltanto in termini di maggior
controllo del cambiamento climatico
porta benefici anche in termini di un
diverso modello di sviluppo economico
porta benefici in termini occupazionali
di miglior competitività per quelle
imprese che per prime si muovono in
questo in questo settore porta benefici
in termini di salute
89 mila morti all'anno calcola l'agenzia
mondiale per la sanità sono quelli che
ogni anno in italia muoiono per malattie
cardiovascolari legate all'inquinamento
urbano
300 mila sono in europa
la cina perché si sta muovendo così
rapidamente nella riduzione dei
combustibili fossili
soprattutto perché sa bene di
inquinamento urbano così elevati che la
popolazione li accetta più e quindi
tagliano le centrali a carbone e le
centrali a gas per sostituirle con
rinnovabili perché inquinano ai città
molto molto meno e questo è un ulteriore
beneficio che potremmo avere da questo
processo di transizione fatto di
elettrificazione il fatto di resista
prodotta con con rinnovabili
a questo punto tocca a noi
e non tocca a noi soltanto con le scelte
di tutti i giorni certo uno può fare
attenzione a quello che consuma a che
cosa mangia a dove investe l'abbiamo
visto prima scegliere oculatamente i
propri investimenti è cruciale per
ridisegnare il nostro il nostro futuro
però c'è una scelta ancora più
fondamentale c'è una fatta comunale che
fate con le vostre mani
il giorno la prossima volta in cui
andate a votare pensateci bene
non votate per chi non capisce questi
problemi o per chi non ha la visione per
affrontarle o per chi non ha il coraggio
di resistere lobby industriali è un
piccolo gesto le vostre mani e una
matita dal futuro di noi dipende da
quello
[Applauso]